this video was made possible by tab for
a cause raised money for charity just by
opening tabs which you were going to do
anyway link in the description so what's
new
it's actually really weird recording
from my own kitchen it feels like I
should have a peanut Buckhannon style
coffee montage but I don't really drink
coffee that much
[Music]
[Music]
so I've never seen anything like this I
graduated from law school in 2008 right
in the middle of the recession and you
can imagine that joining a big firm in
the middle of what was until now the
worst recession that we had seen in
modern times was a very dramatic time to
become a practicing lawyer that is
nothing compared to what it seems like
we're in the middle of right now I'm
from Los Angeles but for the last five
years I have lived in DC and I consider
myself a Washingtonian now and I'm
really worried because I go to the same
gym as Rand Paul get some crap for that
but I thought that because things are so
crazy and so up in the air people might
want an update from legally what does
this mean for the channel and frankly
because we're all basically stuck in our
houses my hope is that the channel will
more or less continue as it always has I
find it incredibly rewarding that people
turn to my channel for entertainment and
education right now I think we could all
use a little bit more information about
the world especially the legal world
that were surrounded by and also a
little entertainment and the little
light-hearted fun from time to time the
power of attorney I get a lot of joy out
of making these videos for people I find
it very rewarding when I get nice
comments in the comment section and when
people leave bad comments your hatred
feels me so for the most part I'm really
just going to try and continue as I
always have with real legal work sort of
drying up because the courts are more or
less closed I'm gonna try an increase
video production it's usually one video
a week on this channel I'm gonna try for
at least two I'm going to keep all of my
staff going I think it's the least that
I could do that in times when we don't
know what's going to happen at least you
know those privileged few who can work
from home I'm going to do my part to try
to make sure that those people
get a paycheck and there are a fair
number of people that rely on me on this
channel and and the work that I do and I
I feel like I owe it to them to try and
continue that work oh and this is an
issue for another day but I have a super
secret legal project that I'm working on
that predates all of this crazy
coronavirus stuff man I can't wait to
tell you what's going on it involves a
lawsuit and it may involve the
government this could be a really really
interesting thing but that's gonna have
to wait until things are a little bit
more solid and it's more in progress but
I can't wait to tell you about it so
that's an update from legal eagle the
channel but I suppose since we're in
this intimate setting we might as well
do an update from Devon personally what
I intend to do personally is whatever I
can to keep things going to try and make
things a little bit better for those
people especially in the service
industry that can't simply work from
home I probably be thanking my delivery
people like they are soldiers returning
home from war on YouTube I'm going to
try and help out as many creators as I
possibly can I would love to do some
collabs with people especially smaller
channels people that are perhaps
interested in the law but might not be
in the legal sector in particular though
I'm certainly open to working with other
legal creators as well obviously
charities are a huge thing we need to
band together to be able to help the
less fortunate those who are really
being affected by this coronavirus
isolation and Quarantine and what seems
like an inevitable economic downturn for
example this video you'll find a link to
tab for a cause which has been a
longtime supporter of this channel it's
great because they're teaming up with a
bunch of coronavirus specific related
charities and it's great because all I
have to do is install Chrome extension
and the surfing which I think we're all
gonna be doing a lot of web surfing
these days just generates ad revenue
that's donated to whatever charities
that you direct it to additionally with
increased video production I'll probably
have some additional opportunities to
partner with charities to directly
sponsor the the channel and we can take
all the proceeds and donate it to there
sherry so those of you that are out
there in the comments if you could leave
me some suggestions on which charities I
should partner with I would greatly
appreciate being able to be directed to
the most effective charities to be able
to combat the coronavirus threat I think
that there are a lot of people doing a
lot of good work out there we owe an
enormous debt of gratitude to doctors
and nurses and other medical staff that
are out there that are on the frontlines
of this thing and they are literally
risking their lives to help everyone
else so in terms of being able to do
what I can as a lawyer with very minimal
to put it graciously very minimal
medical training I would like to be able
to help those that are on the front
lines and in terms of what I intend to
do with my free time now that we all
have a lot of free time well I think
like most people I'm looking forward to
cooking a lot of meals in this kitchen
where I spend a lot of my time I'm
looking forward to doing a whole lot of
bodyweight workouts here at home I'm
looking forward to bettering myself and
doing a lot of eLearning as I'm sure
longtime viewers of the channel no legal
eagle is sponsored by companies like
Skillshare and brilliant and there's a
good reason for it there are companies
out there where I don't necessarily
agree with their mission the great
Chateau legends but it's really easy to
work with companies like Skillshare
brilliant because I really believe in
their mission and I believe in people
getting better by learning the things
that are necessary and then practicing
that on their own and these kind of
elearning platforms allow us a wealth of
knowledge that we wouldn't have had even
ten years ago so like everybody else I'm
gonna learn a lot of new skills maybe
this is too personal but I'm a really
bad dancer so I think I'd like to learn
how to dance especially when no one's
looking so if you have any tips on where
I can go to learn some dance moves
online leave them in the comments and
I'd appreciate it you know I think with
some of this time I'll be on social
media more so you know if you follow me
on Twitter I will probably be trying to
avoid going stir-crazy bye
venting my frustrations on Twitter and
Instagram and you know I don't I don't
feel like now is really the right time
to start a patreon but maybe if if there
was something that I could really add to
the community that you guys wanted and
maybe if the proceeds from the patreon
went to my staff for example or some
other charity I would be open to it if
there if there's something that I can do
to get better acquainted with the all
the legal eagles out there and people
who are interested in the law I I'm open
to ideas so let's end with some optimism
and some thankfulness let's end with a
couple of the things I'm actually really
looking forward to about this whole
isolation and Quarantine situation
number one I'm looking forward to all
the people that are going to be getting
their law degrees on Twitter and
Facebook you might not have heard but
the Zuckerberg Law School in Palo Alto
became an accredited ABA law school so
all of those people who are
pontificating about legal subjects on
social media they probably actually have
their law degrees now what your move is
I'm looking forward to buying a whole
lot of new Scotch one of my favorite
bars in DC Jack Rose is weathering the
storm by selling thousands of bottles of
antique and vintage scotch and I think
I'm just gonna buy all of it bill Thomas
please please save me some bottles I'm
looking forward to all of the new insane
legal theories that I'm going to have to
research and talk about during this
isolation period you know I thought when
Donald Trump became president in 2017
that that alone was going to create a
whole bunch of new legal hypotheticals
and and that was definitely the case but
man there are a whole bunch of crazy
things that we never thought would ever
happen
that we have to figure out the legality
of and it's every day a new legal theory
this is a tough hurricane one of the
wettest we've ever seen from the
standpoint of water and frankly I'm
looking forward to the entire world
coming together for a common cause
this is the first time in my lifetime
and maybe the last time since the Apollo
project that it feels like everyone is
rallying together against a common enemy
and this isn't a common enemy in the
xenophobic sense or even in the in the
true wartime sense but there's something
out there and it affects everyone and
every scientist in the entire world is
trying to fix it things are dire right
now for sure but they're not gonna stay
that way because humans are nothing if
not clever this might be our finest hour
and I'm happy to do what I can to help
out whether it's through making stupid
YouTube videos or through helping out
with charities but I think we all owe
the scientists and doctors out there a
debt of gratitude not only for what
they're doing right now but what they're
going to do because I think that to
paraphrase Andy weir I think we're gonna
science I think we're gonna come out of
this better you know there's light at
the end of the tunnel so that is an
update from legal eagle I will see you
all in court as it were if you want a
really low barrier to entry way of
providing the charity check out the link
to tab for a cause send me a message in
the comments or on Twitter I'm going to
be here what else do I have to do and
thank you to you the viewers the legal
eagles I get a lot of satisfaction for
doing this channel and I'm I'm really
grateful for being in the position that
I am and you guys make it worth it hang
in there we'll get through this and I'll
see you in court